ZDF heute live herzlich willkommen alle
die gerne in Deutschland legal einen
Joint rauchen wollen waren noch nie so
nah dran wie heute in wenigen Minuten
will Gesundheitsminister Karl Lauterbach
vorstellen wie kiffen erlaubt werden
kann das hier hatte getwittert so wird
es sein mit Cem Özdemir damit ist der
Agrarminister gemeint gibt es morgen
also heute neue Eckpunkte die
Legalisierung von Cannabis sie kommt
doch in wenigen Minuten nämlich um 11:30
Uhr soll die Pressekonferenz in Berlin
losgehen wir übertragen sie live wir
sehen schon das Bild der versammelten
Hauptstadt Presse in der
Bundespressekonferenz in Berlin wir
sehen der Minister ist noch nicht da wir
möchten von euch wissen was erwartet ihr
von der Pressekonferenz findet ihr es
gut dass Kiffen erlaubt wird und wenn ja
unter welchen Voraussetzungen und welche
Probleme wieder möglicherweise schreibt
es wie immer in die Kommentare oder per
Mail an die eingeblendete Mailadresse
ZDF
heute-live@zdf.de
wir warten gemeinsam auf diese
Bundespressekonferenz mit unserer
hauptstadtkorrespondentin Nicole
Diekmann zusammen Nicole ist uns
zugeschaltet aus Berlin Nicole das Thema
ist nicht neu es gibt dazu schon ein
Eckpunktepapier das ist ein halbes Jahr
alt was können wir heute erwarten kommt
jetzt der lange erwartete
Gesetzesentwurf
als heute vorgestellt wird und das ist
einigermaßen ungewöhnlich das sind
erstmal nur Eckpunkte du hast es ja
gerade schon gesagt wir kennen schon
Eckpunkte die sind ein halbes Jahr alt
und nach allem was bisher nach außen
gedrungen ist die Kollegen vom
redaktionsnetzwerk Deutschland haben das
Papier schon vorliegen ist das alles was
wahrscheinlich muss man ja sagen wir
haben bisher nur eine Quelle da gleich
vorgestellt werden wird eine Nummer
kleiner als das was man noch vor einem
halben Jahr vorgestellt hat und noch mal
es sind nur Eckpunkte das ist noch
einigermaßen entfernt von einem
Gesetzentwurf
lass uns inhaltlich werden auch du sagst
es wir haben nur eine Quelle und wir
wissen es noch nicht genau aber über was
können wir denn möglicherweise gleich
mehr erfahren wir werden wahrscheinlich
erfahren dass in diesem Eckpunktepapier
man kann es nicht oft genug sagen das
werden wir sicherlich gleich auch noch
ansprechen wie ungewöhnlich das ist ein
Eckpunktepapier schon zu präsentieren
wir werden wahrscheinlich hören das
bestimmte Mengen abgegeben werden dürfen
an Erwachsene ab 18 Jahren also an
Cannabis und Cannabis Produkten also
Marihuana und Haschisch zum Beispiel und
wir werden hören und das ist das was ich
eben meinte mit sicherlich eine Nummer
kleiner als das was man ursprünglich mal
vor hatte
in sogenannten
Cannabis social Clubs das bedeutet es
soll
kleine angemeldete Gruppen geben die an
ihre Mitglieder Cannabis abgeben dürfen
da ist die Rede von maximal 50 Gramm im
Monat und man sollte auch maximal
zweimal nur etwas abholen dürfen das
sind so einige der wenigen Eckpunkte die
wir im Moment kennen
ich gucke hier gerade mal in die Chats
und wenn ich jetzt einen nicht
repräsentatives Stimmungsbild erstellen
würde würde ich sagen hier ist die
Mehrheit für die Freigabe el Gommern
kommandante schreibt auf Youtube ja für
Brokkoli gibt das hanfrei steht hier auf
Youtube also hier ist ähm hier träumen
viele von der von der Legalisierung wenn
ich das jetzt auf diesen ersten Blick so
erfasse Nicole warum hat es denn so
lange gedauert und warum ist es denn
offenbar so schwierig
ja warum hat es so lange gedauert da ist
natürlich immer die erste Erklärung für
diese Ampel die ja auch tatsächlich
stimmt da kamen den einiges ähm völlig
Unerwartetes auf den Tisch unter anderem
zum Beispiel der Krieg Russlands gegen
die Ukraine das hat viel was man sich in
den Koalitionsvertrag geschrieben hatte
womit man angetreten war als sogenannte
vortrittskoalition die man ja sein
musste erstmal ins Hintertreffen und
dann noch mal von einem halben Jahr
haben wir schon mal Eckpunkte gesehen da
gab es schon die ersten Stimmen die sich
meldeten und die dann auch immer lauter
wurden dass das was man sich vorgestellt
hatte gegen EU und gegen internationales
Recht verstoßen könnte und darauf ist
auch zurückzuführen dass man jetzt eben
doch noch meinen Gang zurückgeschaltet
hat in dem was man vor hat
kannst du uns noch mal ganz kurz
zusammenfassen wie die Position der
Parteien zur Legalisierung ist
naja die Ampel hat sich eben in den
Koalitionsvertrag geschrieben dass sie
eine Legalisierung anstrebt da gab es im
Vorfeld einige Abstufungen fangen wir
bei den Grünen an die schon seit langem
die Position vertreten man müsse
Cannabis Cannabis Produkte legalisieren
aus unterschiedlichen Gründen zum
Beispiel und die Beschaffung zu
entkriminalisieren und die dann quasi
die Daseinsberechtigung zu entziehen den
Schwarzmarkt also weitestgehend zu
zerstören mit all seinen Nebenwirkungen
wie zum Beispiel Kriminalität dann gibt
es die FDP die sich ins Wahlprogramm vor
der Bundestagswahl auch die
Legalisierung geschrieben hatte und es
gibt die SPD ähm die da etwas
vorsichtiger war und auch für eine
Legalisierung eingetreten ist und immer
noch Eintritt in ihrem Wahlprogramm aber
ähm auch den Vermerk hatte es müssten
lizenzierte
Einrichtungen sein die Cannabis abgeben
und diese müssten auch Monitoring
betreiben um eine langfristige oder um
langfristige Erkenntnisse auch
liefern zu können wir sinnvoll eine
solche eine solche Legalisierung
schwieriges Wort eigentlich ist wie
sieht es die Opposition
fangen wir mit der Linken an die ist da
nämlich eher auf Linie der Ampel die
Linkspartei ist für die Legalisierung
von Cannabis auf der anderen Seite
stehen
Unionsparteien und AFD die AFD ist
lediglich für den Einsatz von Cannabis
Produkten für medizinische Zwecke was
was sowieso heute schon Realität ist in
Deutschland das ist seit ich glaube 2011
zugelassen
und die Unionsparteien sprechen auch
jetzt aktuell von einem völlig falschen
Weg die sind gegen eine Legalisierung
Nicole wenn wir hier erst noch mal einen
Blick in die Bundespressekonferenz
werfen das tun wir mal weil viele
Userinnen und User wissen wollen wann
geht's denn los wir sehen da sind zwar
schon viele Presse Leute versammelt aber
auf dem Podium tut sich noch nichts also
sobald die Minister kommen wir sagen
noch mal dazu es ist Karl Lauterbach die
Minister Karl Lauterbach als
Gesundheitsminister und Özdemir als
Agrarminister sobald Sie also kommen
fangen wir natürlich auch live mit der
Übertragung der PK an aber bis dahin
Nicole lass uns noch mal ein bisschen
auf die die Zahlen gucken und da meldet
die Bundeszentrale für gesundheitliche
Aufklärung dass der Cannabiskonsum
gestiegen ist und zwar bei den 12 bis
17-Jährigen hat jeder elfte 9,3% schon
mal Cannabis konsumiert und bei jungen
Erwachsenen zwischen 18 und 25 hat mit
50,8% mehr als die Hälfte eigene
konsumerfahrung
wenn ich die Zahn richtig gelesen habe
dann hat sich das gesteigert in den
letzten Jahren das hat also zugenommen
der Konsum jetzt sagen ja viele
Befürworter wenn wir das legalisieren
dann bilden wir quasi nur die Realität
ab und schaffen politische
Rahmenbedingungen für eine Tatsache die
sowieso schon da ist
das ist das eine Argument genau das
andere Argument ich habe das ja eben
schon kurz angesprochen man will den
Dealern quasi das Handwerk legen denn
die das Argument ist wer Cannabis
verkauft Haschisch Marihuana hat oft
auch viel härteres noch im Sortiment das
heißt die Hemmschwelle für Leute die die
Hemmschwelle wird gesenkt und
natürlich auch
die beschaffungs der Beschaffungsweg
wird deutlich abgekürzt für Leute um an
härtere Drogen zu kommen wie zum
Beispiel Heroin ähm ein anderes Argument
ist auch gibt man lizenziert also vom
Staat überwacht
Cannabis ab dann ist zum einen klar wie
hoch konzentriert das ist der THC-Gehalt
z.B ist völlig klar und auch nicht zu
vergessen das Argument dadurch nimmt der
Staat Steuern ein dass man wiederum je
nach parteiausrichtung zum Beispiel gibt
es den Vorschlag in Präventionsprogramm
in Aufklärungsprogramm e in
drogenpräventionsprogramm könnte
Nicole was ist denn mit dem Aspekt der
Kontrolle viele sagen ja auch im Moment
die Polizei die Gerichte sind viel zu
sehr damit beschäftigt kleine Mengen die
im Moment bestraft werden müssen zu
verfolgen und blockieren damit die
Justiz ist das an der Stelle auch ein
gutes Argument für die Befürworter der
Legalisierung ganz genau das gehört auch
zu den zentralen Argumenten der
Befürworter wobei man eins sagen muss
wenn man sich die Gesetzeslage heute
anguckt wirkt es auf den ersten Blick
sehr klar es gibt das
Betäubungsmittelgesetz und darunter
fällt auch Cannabis der Besitz von
Cannabis von Haschisch von Marihuana ist
in Deutschland verboten klingt wie
gesagt sehr klar dann gibt es aber
Einschränkungen es gibt den sogenannten
Eigenbedarf und der wiederum ist auch
das ist ein Fest den da begriff in
geringen Mengen ich gucke einmal kurz
kommt noch niemand ist erlaubt das
bedeutet je nach Bundesland ist es halt
weder etwas komplizierter sind 6 Gramm
zum Beispiel Haschisch wenn ich damit
erwischt werde in Anführungszeichen kann
die Staatsanwaltschaft erwägen daraus
keine Straftat zu machen dass nicht
weiter zu ahnten und damit mich
Durchkommen zu lassen wie gesagt das
liegt im Ermessen der Staatsanwaltschaft
es gibt Bundesländer wie zum Beispiel
hier in Berlin da gehören noch 10 Gramm
Haschisch zum Beispiel zu geringen
Mengen in den meisten Bundesländern sind
es sechs Gramm trotzdem wird es immer
wieder geahndet es gibt auch ganz klare
Regeln wann es nicht in Ordnung ist
Cannabis z.B auch weiterzugeben von
Erwachsenen dann unter 18-Jährige ist es
streng verboten kann man kann dafür im
Gefängnis landen so bei diesen Fällen
diese ungeklärt sind die ich eben
genannt habe zum Beispiel geringe Menge
Eigenbedarf ja oder nein wird es in
Schulen konsumiert wird es in
Jugendeinrichtungen konsumiert auch da
ist es verboten da sagen eben die
Befürworter einer Legalisierung
natürlich unter bestimmten Umständen
damit entlasten wir auch die ohnehin ja
völlig überlastete Justiz wenn eine
klare Rechtslage herrscht
Nicole hier schreibt einen Usern namens
la muerte Jungs es wird noch lange
dauern bis es legal ist mindestens ein
Jahr wir sehen es dauert länger bis die
PK beginnt das stellen wir gerade fest
die Minister sind noch nicht da wir
warten Haren einfach weiter tapfer aus
und besprechen das Thema Nicole was ist
mit der Frage von languate wie lange
dauert das bis aus diesem
Gesetzesentwurf tatsächlich dann ein
Gesetz wird und das legal ist
das ist eine gute Frage ich habe es ich
habe das ich habe das Keyboard gesagt
das ist ein ein Eck Punkte
genau Eckpunktepapier wir könnten da
fast schon Trinkspiel draus machen da
sind wir bei einer Droge die schon
legalisiert ist in Deutschland ähm ja
das kann durchaus noch und da ja dauern
wir wissen ja überhaupt noch gar nicht
wie das ist Eckpunktepapier bei den
anderen
Koalitionspartnern ankommt jetzt treten
zwei Minister aus zwei der drei
ampelparteien heute gemeinsam vor die
Presse msdemir als grüner und Karl
Lauterbach als SPD Politiker wir gehen
mal davon aus dass das auch mit der FDP
abgestimmt ist aber das kann ja noch
einige Schleifen drehen und ich will
noch mal einen Punkt nennen wir haben es
ja eben schon gesagt so ein paar Punkte
die schon nach außen gedrungen sind was
übrigens auch dazu gehören soll ist dass
der Besitz von drei Cannabis Pflanzen
bei mir zu Hause in Zukunft auch legal
sein soll aber es soll ja eben auch
diese Clubs geben diese sogenannten
Social Clubs wenn man Kanada guckt das
ist finde ich ein ganz gutes Beispiel
weil die uns vier Jahre jetzt voraus
sind die haben vor vier Jahren Cannabis
legalisiert und haben da sogenannte
lizenzierte Shops eingerichtet zwischen
der Legalisierung und der Eröffnung des
ersten Shops lag ein Jahr also ein Jahr
lang konnte man quasi noch gar nicht
legal Cannabis erwerben das ist jetzt
eher da ist noch Luft nach oben was das
Verfahren angeht das muss nicht heißen
das ist hierzulande auch so laufen wird
kann es aber deswegen ist es äh
wahnsinnig schwer jetzt schon Zeitraum
zu nennen binnen dem dann Cannabis
tatsächlich legal ist und auch legal
erwerbbar ist
Nicole jetzt tut sich hier was äh in
Berlin denke ich sag nach ganz kurz für
den Grünen Champion mir ist das auch ein
Punkt in der bei seiner Partei machen
muss die Grünen sind ja schon lange
dafür Cannabis zu legalisieren ganz kurz
noch bis es los geht
muss ein Punkt machen die komplette
Ampel muss ein Punkt machen die haben
wir erinnern uns gerade drei Tage
Koalitionsausschuss hinter sich alles
was irgendwie nach Handlung aussieht
nach gemeinsamen Beschlüssen nach
Umsetzung des Koalitionsvertrages geht
aus Konto aus Punktekonto diese
Koalition die zwischenzeitlich
wahnsinnig zerstritten wirkte und damit
sehen wir dass die Herren Platz nehmen
auch der Kollege Alex Pool der die
Bundespressekonferenz heute leitet wenn
ich das richtig sehen kann hat Platz
genommen wird gleich begrüßen wir sehen
den Agrarminister chemnes Cem Özdemir
Entschuldigung wir sind den
Gesundheitsminister Karl Lauterbach und
wir gehen live nach Berlin
dann können wir anfangen wir bitten die
Verspätung zu entschuldigen
herzlich willkommen in der
Bundespressekonferenz liebe Kolleginnen
und liebe Kollegen wir begrüßen bei uns
den Bundesminister für Gesundheit Herrn
Professor Dr Karl Lauterbach und den
Bundesminister für Ernährung und
Landwirtschaft und beste mir herzlich
Willkommen bei uns sie sind da um uns
Ihre Cannabis Gesetzespläne vorzustellen
der Bundesgesundheitsminister beginnt
und dann ist er mir bitte ja vielen Dank
für diese Gelegenheit hier bei ihnen
vorzutragen erneut bekommen haben das
wissen wir zu schätzen ich möchte
einsteigen indem ich vielleicht mit ein
paar Hintergründen also beginne weshalb
macht die andere Regierung dieses
fortschrittsprojekt Cannabis
Legalisierung welches Problem wollen wir
damit lösen und da muss man in den
Vordergrund immer wieder stellen dass
unsere bisherige Cannabis
kontrollpolitik gescheitert ist die
Beschaffungskriminalität und die
Verstöße gegen das
Betäubungsmittelgesetz haben in der vor
coronazeit stetig zugenommen ich bringe
ein Beispiel alleine in Bayern wurden
55.000 Fälle im Jahr verzeichnet der
überwiegende Teil davon 35.000 Fälle
Cannabis bezogen bundesweit ist die
Anzahl der erfassten rauschgift-delikte
Verstöße gegen das
Betäubungsmittelgesetz seit 2011 jedes
Jahr gestiegen seit 2011 jedes Jahr
gestiegen und wir haben zum Schluss
jetzt 21 haben zwar 3000
361.000 Fälle gehabt somit also kann man
sagen wir schaffen kein Problem sondern
wir suchen ein Problem zu lösen und wir
wissen auch dass wir mit der alleinigen
Verschärfung des Strafrechtes nicht
weiterkommen dass deine begrüße ich auch
noch einmal ganz ausdrücklich die
Vorschläge die also her Mensch heute
morgen gemacht hat aber wie gesagt wir
gehen einen anderen Weg und das Ziel ist
ganz klar dass wir beim Cannabiskonsum
mehr Sicherheit bieten wollen wir wollen
Verunreinigungen schützen wir wollen
davor schützen dass es toxische
beinengungen gibt wir wollen davor
schützen dass über Cannabis der Einstieg
in stärkere Drogen stattfindet wir
wollen die Jugend besser schützen wir
wollen den Schwarzmarkt bekämpfen wir
wollen den die Drogen Kriminalität
zurückdrängen wir wollen dich stetig
zunehmende Toxizität der Produkte wollen
wir in den Griff bekommen somit wir
wollen kein Problem schaffen sondern ein
ungelöstes Problem wollen wir helfen zu
lösen dafür hatten wir Eckpunkte
vorgelegt diese Eckpunkte haben wir mit
der Europäischen Kommission Ende
November sehr intensiv besprochen das
waren gute Gespräche das war
vertrauensvolle gute Gespräche da sind
wir dann aber auf der Grundlage zu also
dem Schluss gekommen auf der Grundlage
dieser Gespräche dass der damalige
Eckpunkte entworfen und nicht also
weiterbringen würde um unserer Ziele zu
verfolgen wir haben daher neue Eckpunkte
entwickelt die wir heute gerne mit Ihnen
besprechen wollen und zwar wollen wir
die ursprünglichen Ziele nicht verändern
ich bleibe dabei mehr Sicherheit im
Konsum Konsum eher einschränken
Schwarzmarkt zurückdrängen besser
Jugendschutz weniger bimingungen weniger
Drogenkriminalität des bleiben die Ziele
der ampelregierung in dieser Hinsicht
aber wir haben jetzt also ein zwei
säulen-modell aufgebaut eine schnelle
Säule und eine Säule wo wir Modell
Vorhaben machen in dieser schnellen
Säule geht es darum also von Verboten
wegzukommen wir wollen eine also
Möglichkeit schaffen sich legal mit also
Cannabis zu versorgen und diese
kontrollierte also Abgabe die soll so
funktionieren dass nicht gewinnen
orientierte Vereinigungen von mir aus
können Sie auch von Cannabis Clubs
sprechen also nicht gewinnorientierte
Vereinigungen mit maximal 500
Mitgliedern können dann zu genusszwecken
Cannabisprodukte anbauen für den
Eigenkonsum ausschließlich wir werden
dann die Landesbehörden der
entsprechenden Mengen Qualitäts- und
jugendschutzvorgaben kontrollieren wir
werden also dann bestimmte Vorgaben
machen was also aus eigenen besitzt also
und auch als Bezug über diese
Cannabis Clubs ermöglicht wird das kann
also 25 Gramm Cannabis dort erwerben pro
Monat 50 Gramm bei den unter 21-jähriges
im monatliche Obergrenze bei 30 Gramm
also zu sehen das können für den eigenen
Anbau 7 Samen oder fünf Stecklinge
bezogen werden der Eigenanbau bleibt
erlaubt in den Rahmenbedingungen die Sie
kennen und drei weibliche Pflanzen pro
Person so also aufgebracht dass sie also
vor Kinder und Jugendlichen geschützt
sind alles was Kinder und Jugendliche
angeht unter 18 bleibt verboten dann
soll sich nichts ändern wir verändern
aber die Grundlage für den Jugendschutz
wir wollen es so machen dass bei den
unter 18-Jährigen wenn der Konsum dort
festgestellt wird verbindlich
entsprechende Programme angeboten werden
proventionsprogramme für Minderjährige
ich habe bei andere Gelegenheiten darauf
hingewiesen dass wir immer klar sein der
Wissenschaft sehen welche negativen
Konsequenzen der Konsum in der Konsum
hat bei Kindern und Jugendlichen hat
also wir sehen dann einen also auch
bedeutsamen lassen Leistungsabbau in der
Schule es wird dann weniger studiert
dass fallen die Leistungen zurück aber
viel bedeutsamer sind tatsächlich auch
die uns jetzt mittlerweile bekannten
Veränderungen im Gehirn von
Heranwachsenden die dann später die man
auch messen kann und die dann später zu
einer stärkeren Anfälligkeit für
Depressionen Psychosen aber auch für
Angst Bewegungen also verantwortlich
sind somit ist der Kinder und
Jugendschutz für unseren allergrößter
Bedeutung und sein zentrales Ziel hier
unser zwei Säulen also diese erste Säule
der nicht kommerzielle Eigenanbau durch
diese also
cannabisclubs also ist also die
Möglichkeit hier den Schwarzmarkt
zurückzudrängen die Reinheit der
Produkte zu gewährleisten den
Jugendschutz also besser zu
gewährleisten in einer zweiten Stufe in
einer zweiten Säule wollen wir dann
durch regionale Modellvorhaben das ganze
erweitern und kommerzielle Lieferketten
aufbauen diese kommerziellen
Lieferketten kennen sie ja aus den
ursprünglichen Eckpunkten bereits und da
geht es dann darum darzustellen dass wir
durch diese kommerziellen Lieferketten
tatsächlich also den Anbau noch sicherer
gestalten können und dass wir dort also
die Regelungen dann auch von staatlicher
Seite noch besser kontrollieren können
und das wollen wir auswerten in
regionalen also im Modellversuchen über
fünf Jahre laufen also
zwischenauswertungen sind vorgesehen so
dass wir gute Botschaften auch durch
zwischenauswertungen vermitteln können
all das wird begleitet werden durch eine
konzertierte Aktion der Bundesregierung
um zu erreichen dass wir in Europa für
diese progressive
präventionsorientierte Cannabispolitik
Unterstützer finden und diese
Unterstützer soll uns dann helfen auch
in Europa die Cannabispolitik
umzustellen ich will das mal einfach
ausdrücken ein bisschen weg von also
nicht funktionierenden Verschärfungen
des Strafrechtes hin zu einer
Präventionspolitik und einer
Qualitätspolitik dahin gehen dass wir
die Produkte reinhalten dass wir den
Schwarzmarkt zurückdrängen die dritte
die Kriminalität zurückdenken dass wir
also das Problem tatsächlich entschärfen
indem wir mehr Kontrolle und mehr
Präventionen hineinbringen ich möchte
mich bei allen Ministerien die hier
mitgearbeitet haben dann ins gesamt fünf
oder so
Ressource
daran sehr intensiv dabei erwartet
möchte ich mich ganz herzlich bedanken
wo ich meine es heute leider
urlaubsbedingt verhindert sonst würde er
hat auch ein wesentlichen Beitrag
geleistet wäre heute auch hier aber umso
mehr freue ich mich dass man Kollege
kennen Ärzte mir hier dabei ist der auch
ganz wesentlicher Anteil am Projekt hat
meine Damen und Herren
ich sitze hier heute als Bundesminister
für Ernährung und Landwirtschaft aber
ich sitze natürlich auch wie sie gerade
eben schon gehört haben auch als
Vertreter einer politischen Kraft wir
haben das in der Koalitionsvereinbarung
ja die drei ampelparteien gemeinsam
verabredet das setzen wir jetzt
umbringendes auf den Weg und ich will
zunächst mal ein Wort des Dankes sagen
wie mein Kollege Professor Dr Karl
Lauterbach schon gesagt hat an die
Beteiligten Häuser aber ganz besonderes
an den Bundesgesundheitsminister und
sein Haus dass das federführend
erarbeitet hat das ist ja kein ganz
einfaches Projekt dass wir hier angehen
weil es eben nicht nur eine kontroverse
Debatte der Vergangenheit versucht jetzt
endlich eine Lösung zuzuführen sondern
gleichzeitig eben auch europäisches
Recht betroffen ist gleichzeitig
internationales Recht betroffen ist und
das alles unter einen Hut zu bringen
nach vorne lösungsorientiert anzugehen
das ist sicherlich eine große Sache was
wir hier machen ist nichts anderes als
dass wir einen großen gesellschaftlichen
Konflikt endlich eine Lösung zuführen
die Vogel strauß-politik der vergangenen
Jahre in der Vergangenheit lassen wir
bringen zwei Dinge zusammen auf der
einen Seite gehen wir das Hand frei und
auf der anderen Seite stärken wir den
Kinder und Jugendschutz beides gemeinsam
gehen wir an das ist entscheidend der
Konsum von Cannabis ist eine
gesellschaftliche Realität und wenn ich
mir die Jugendorganisation auch der
Parteien anschaue habe ich das Gefühl
das ist ein parteiübergreifendes
Phänomen aber immer mal bitte schön
nicht unehrlich sein ich habe das Gefühl
dass das Thema wir haben ja gerade eben
die Zahlen vom Bundesgesundheitsminister
gehört weder an geographischen Grenzen
Halt macht noch ein politischen Grenzen
Halt macht noch ein
Weltanschauungsfragen Halt macht das ist
eine Realität und sie weg zu diskutieren
schafft sie nicht aus der Welt ganz im
Gegenteil wir dürfen die Augen vor der
Qualität nicht verschließen diese
Politik wie sie bislang vertrieben hat
ging zu Lasten unserer Kinder und
Jugendlichen ging zulassen der
Gesundheit der konsumierenden sie ging
aber auch und darauf lege ich wer zu
lassen das Strafverfolgungsbehörden das
politische Ziel der Kriminalisierung von
Cannabis ist über die Jahrzehnte hinweg
gescheitert das Ziel Menschen vom Konsum
von Cannabis abzubringen wurde zu keinem
Zeitpunkt erreicht stattdessen hat man
Schwarzmarkt geschaffen und die
politische Sackgasse wer sich heute
nicht freuen wird und das auch mal sehr
klar zu sagen das sind die illegalen die
Kriminellen Dealer die werden sich nicht
freuen über den heutigen Tag der
Schwarzmarkt wird sie wenn man so will
schwarz ärgern das ist auch gut so wir
setzen hier um was wir in der
Koalitionsvereinbarung uns vorgenommen
haben einerseits eine liberale und
andererseits eine gesundheitsorientierte
Cannabispolitik und arbeiten das ab
es geht um eine kontrollierte Abgabe an
Erwachsenen das ist ganz entscheidend
und gleichzeitig in maximalen Schutz
unserer Kinder und unserer Jugendlichen
warum neue Eckpunkte Karl Lauterbach hat
es gerade eben schon gesagt zu den
Eckpunkten im Oktober im vergangenen
Jahr
in Sachen Cannabis zu genusszwecken
haben wir nach dem Gespräch mit der
EU-Kommission eben auch die Völker und
EU-rechtlichen Rahmen mussten wir
weiterentwickeln um da nicht mit dem
Kopf gegen die Wand zu laufen unser Ziel
ist es weiterhin und es bleibt die
Legalisierung von genusskanal bis dann
durch den Gesundheitsschutz der
Konsumenten und Konsumenten zu
verbessern und den Jugendschutz zu
stärken und den Schwarzmarkt auszukommen
wir haben die Eckpunkte auf der
Grundlage angepasst mit dem Ziel das
Cannabis schnellstmöglich und
pragmatisch die Kriminalisierung
umgesetzt wird das Ganze aber konform
mit dem Gemeinschaftsrecht das sind halt
nun mal Grenzen setzt die wir beachten
müssen die wir aber das sage ich auch
ausreizen
das Ergebnis ist eine stimmige ist eine
pragmatische Cannabispolitik mit der
Perspektive private Anbau Besitz und
Konsum legal zu machen das basiert auf
zwei Säulen die erste Säule des
cannabisprojekt nimmt heute den nächsten
Schritt so dass der Konsum noch in
diesem Jahr legal wird der Gesetzentwurf
kommt noch im April durch den
kontrollierten Anbau und die Abgabe von
sauberen Cannabis im Rahmen von Cannabis
Clubs also in der ersten Säule stärken
wir den Gesundheitsschutz niemand soll
mehr bei Dealern kaufen müssen ohne zu
wissen was man sich da einhandelt damit
entziehen wir auch der organisierten
Kriminalität in dem Bereich den Boden
die er selbst vor Kindern und
Jugendlichen sich nicht zurückhalten und
keine Kuppel haben die Clubs über die
Mengen hat der Bundesgesundheitsminister
schon was gesagt ist wiederhole ich
nicht wir schaffen praxistaugliche
konsumorte
dann sensiblen Orten auch darauf lege
ich Wert wie Schulhöfen oder Kitas ist
der Konsum ausgeschlossen die zweite
Säule mit der zweiten Säule in Form von
regionalen Modellprojekten loten wir die
Möglichkeiten einer kommerziellen
Lieferkette in der Feldstudie aus die
zweite Säule soll wenn man so will eine
Brücke schlagen zu einer künftigen
bundesweiten Regelung der Produktion dem
Vertrieb und der Abgabe von Genuss
Cannabis in einem kontrollierten
gewerblichen Maßstab auch da gehen wir
zügig voran wenn im April der
Gesetzentwurf kommt soll nach der
Sommerpause bereits die zweite Säule auf
dem Weg gebracht werden auch da schlagen
wir ein völlig neues Kapitel der
Cannabispolitik auf also noch mal
konsumierende schützen aber nicht
bevormunden und die Polizei und unsere
Justiz entlassen zum Schluss ich bin mir
sicher der eine oder andere
wahlkämpfende der sonst überall immer
Verbote wittert sie ahnen wen ich da
meinen könnte wird gerade hier nach
Verboten rufen da wird man auch sehen
wie doppelbödig diese Politik ist und
noch eins es wird sicherlich auch der
Angriff kommen haben die denn nichts
Wichtigeres zu tun in der Ampel wir
haben wichtiges zu tun und tun das aber
uns hindert auch niemand Multitasking zu
betreiben wir lösen hier ein wichtiges
Problem und widmen uns gleichzeitig den
aktuell großen Krisen das kann man
gemeinsam abarbeiten es geht noch mal um
die kontrollierte Abgabe einer wachsende
die selbst entscheiden dürfen ob sie
konsumieren wollen und es geht um eine
Maximierung des Schutzes unserer Kinder
und Jugendlichen und schließlich um eine
Entlastung von Justiz und Polizei das
ist uns wichtig und das machen wir jetzt
danke dann kommen wir zu ihren Fragen
viele haben sich schon gemeldet ihr
wisst das Lernen fassen sich kurz fragen
Sie präzise eine Nachfrage zum Thema
jung fängt an dann sind Sie dran bitte
der große Unterschied zu ihm jeden
ursprünglichen Vorschlag also die
Eckpunkte ist ja das ist jetzt doch
keine freien Abgabestellen gibt also
verkaufen Fachgeschäften oder Apotheken
können Sie noch mal uns uns erklären was
Brüssel jetzt genau damit zu tun hat
also warum ist jetzt ein Modellprojekt
braucht was regional begrenzt und
befristet ist und die zweite Frage
Lauterbach sind die meisten ja die
ursprünglichen Ziele hätten sich nicht
verändert das ist aber das ist aber so
Leute weil sie haben selbst gesagt dass
sie den Schwarzmarkt wegbekommen wollen
die ganze Kriminalität wegbekommen
wollen jetzt reden sie nur noch davon
den Schwarzmarkt einzudämmen also wissen
sie selbst dass der Schwarzmarkt durch
dieses Projekt jetzt doch nicht weit
kommt
ja vielen Dank zunächst einmal
die
Fachgeschäfte sollen ja kommen aber sie
werden kommen nach dem erfolgreichen
Modellprojekt und wir haben also in
Brüssel sehr gute Gespräche gefüllt
vertrauliche Gespräche und also diese
Gespräche haben also zum Ergebnis
geführt dass wir glauben dass wir über
diesen Weg tatsächlich das genau später
erreichen werden nicht nur für
Deutschland sondern auch als also
Vorbild einer europäischen
Cannabispolitik dass es eben diesen also
verkauft dann geben kann in wenn Sie so
wollen lizenzierten fachliche aber ohne
Modellprojekte wäre das nicht
darstellbar gewesen und ich bitte um
Verständnis dass ich aus diesem
verstaulichen Gesprächen jetzt nicht
also präziser berichten möchte weil sie
die Vertraulichkeit zugesagt haben aber
Sie können sicher sein dass das sie sich
nicht verändert hat das gleiche gilt
auch für das Ziel also den Schwarzmarkt
also einzudämmen oder zu beseitigen es
ist natürlich klar dass das zentrale
Ziel das ist das der Schwarzmarkt ganz
verschwindet aber also ich glaube dass
wir realistisch sein müssen bisher ist
der Schwarzmarkt immer größer geworden
jetzt gehen wir hier Meilen Schritte
also in Richtung einer Eindämmung oder
Beseitigung und das Ziel ist somit das
gleiche sie deuten ja an dass wir davon
ausgehen dass der Schwarzmarkt nicht so
schnell verschwindet durch diese Clubs
wie er verschwunden wäre durch die also
lizenzierten Geschäfte da bin ich
ehrlich gesagt nicht sicher und zwar
deshalb weil also diese Clubs im Aufbau
sehr viel einfacher sind das geht ja
nach dem Vereinsrecht und daher kann ich
mir sogar vorstellen dass der Aufbau
dieser Struktur schneller geht als in
der ursprünglich gedacht hatte aber
unbenommen darüber jetzt zu spekulieren
macht keinen Sinn diese andere
Möglichkeit erst vorgestellt hatten
hatten wir nicht ich habe aber damals
auch immer gesagt wir wissen nicht ob
wir sie bekommen daher prüfe ich das bei
der Europäischen Kommission das habe ich
immer gesagt ich habe damals nie den
Fehler gemacht
also etwas anzukündigen was ich nicht
wirklich sicher weiß ich möchte einfach
nicht einen Fehler machen den soweit ich
mich erinnere an also
Bundesverkehrsminister möglicherweise
mal gemacht hat dass er die Rechnung
ohne den wird gemacht hat ich habe immer
gesagt also wir machen hier die Rechnung
mit dem wird und so ist es heute auch
ganz kurz
unser Ziel ist es auch dass wir schauen
dass wir nicht durch den Bundesrat
müssen unser Ziel ist es auch bei der
Säule eins dass wir nicht notifizieren
müssen ins in Brüssel wir wollen ja dass
sich was ändert wir wollen nicht
ankündigen angekündigt wurde jetzt genug
in den letzten Jahren so das soll sich
ja substantiell zeitnah was ändern darum
haben wir das so formuliert und wird der
Gesetzentwurf so sein aber mit dem
zweiten Teil mit dem Modellversuch da
machen wir genau das dass wir eben
schauen wie sieht das aus mit Verkauf
wie sieht es aus mit Anbau in
Deutschland da sind uns halt nun mal
enge Grenzen gesetzt was die rechtliche
Frage angeht aber und da greife ich
ihren Punkt auf deshalb wollen wir ja
parallel dazu in Brüssel politisch aktiv
werden als bundesdeutschland mit Staaten
die das ähnlich sind die ein ähnlichen
Blick haben auf die bisherige
Cannabispolitik in Brüssel dass wir dort
versuchen Mehrheiten zu organisieren für
eine andere Politik was den Schwarzmarkt
angeht wenn ich ihn gar nicht
grundsätzlich widersprechen da besteht
ein gewisses Spannungsverhältnis
zwischen der Frage wie sind die Auflagen
so wie wirkt sich das auf den Preis aus
und natürlich auf die Frage der Qualität
Stichwort Beimischungen Stichwort
thc-anteil wir kommen von der
gesundheitsperspektive von der
verbraucherschutzperspektive aber da
besteht natürlich gewisse
Spannungsverhältnis unsere Hoffnung ist
es dass wir einfach dadurch dass wir mit
den Social Clubs eine legale Alternative
schaffen und mit der anderen Möglichkeit
dass sich privat Pflanzen habe dass ich
darüber eine attraktive Alternative
schaffe so dass der Schwarzmarkt
eingedämmt zurückgedrängt wird das
Versprechen dass er vollständig
verschwindet das wäre nicht seriös in
einer idealen Welt würde man jetzt hier
sitzen und sagen wir machen
wissenschaftsbasierte Politik wir
schauen uns Studien gemeinsam an und
kommen dann zu ähnlichen Erkenntnissen
und setzen es um leider ist es nicht
ganz so ist da auch immer noch viele
Ideologie mit am Start das wissen wir
und darum müssen wir jetzt diesen Weg
wählen aber ich gebe die Hoffnung nicht
auf dass wir werden es ja
wissenschaftlich begleiten dass die Zahl
der Anhänger wächst und dass wir darüber
dann hoffentlich auch andere Mehrheiten
generieren so dass wir dann auch noch
mal weitere Schritte gehen können
nächste Frage
aus niederländischer
öffentlich-rechtliche Rundfunk deswegen
auch eine niederländische Frage
ja in den Niederländer Niederlande ist
Marihuana natürlich bereits teilweise
legal und was haben sie aus dem
niederländischen System gelernt und gibt
es vielleicht auch Sachen die sie
bewusst nicht übernehmen
[Musik]
ja vielen Dank also erstmal zum
Hintergrund ich kenne die
niederländische Cannabispolitik sehr gut
ich komme aus dem Westen des Westens
wenn man so will habe in Aachen studiert
und komme aus dem grenznah aufgewachsen
viele Freunde von mir sind erste also an
der Grenze mit denen ich zur Schule
gegangen bin und da kenne ich das
niederländische Modell sehr gut das ist
für uns wenn ich ehrlich sein soll kein
Vorbild gewesen und ist wird es auch
nicht sein zum einen also ich habe ja
eben schon häufiger von Cannabis Clubs
gesprochen da wird Cannabis also nicht
kommerziell also produziert für die
Vereinsmitglieder aber der Konsum wird
dort also nicht schwerpunktmäßig
stattfinden sondern also es ist
tatsächlich dann also nicht eine neue
sollen keine konsumräume geschaffen
werden die würde ich sehr also
problematisch bewerten wollen ich möchte
mir hier nicht zutrauen die
niederländische Cannabispolitik in der
Grenze zu bewerten aber mein Eindruck
ist der das ist sicherlich etwas was Du
nicht wollen wir wollen auch den Bezug
hat qualitativ verbessern und
Bundesminister zu mir hat es eben sehr
eloquent ausgedrückt der hat es auf den
Punkt gebracht wir wollen also eben
Verunreinigungen vermeiden Beimengungen
toxische Dosierungen der Versuch das
also mehr Abhängigkeit geschaffen wird
das wollen wir alles also durch diese
also durch diesen legalen Anbau in den
also nicht kommerziellen Vereinigungen
schaffen und nicht Schwarzmarkt
wegbringen in den Niederlanden ist genau
umgekehrt dort wird sozial konsumiert
aber über den Schwarzmarkt quasi
importiert und daher wird dort aus
meiner Sicht etwas gemacht was die
Nachteile kombiniert ich habe an
üblichen Schwarzmarkt und viel
Kriminalität und also unsichere Produkte
aber einen gemeinsamen Konsum und wir
wollen also quasi den Schwarzmarkt
zurückdenken
keiner bei Menge und keine Toxizität
aber keinen gemeinsamen Konsum somit
kann man fast sagen dass wenn man darf
das nicht zu
holzschnittartig bewerten aber wir haben
uns am Holländischen Modell eher daran
orientiert wie man es nicht machen
sollte
Fragen von den Kolleginnen in der Mitte
da müssen wir noch mal ein Zeichen geben
hier hat sich glaube ich gemeldet ja
dann die Kollegin zweimal
Liebe ZuschauerInnen also die
Bundespressekonferenz aus Berlin mit
Gesundheitsminister Karl Lauterbach zur
Legalisierung vom Kiffen in Deutschland
die Fragen werden weiter gestellt aber
wir wollen das gerne hier im Stream
zusammenfassen und weiter besprechen
auch mit einem Suchtexperten gleich im
Anschluss fassen wir aber erst noch mal
zusammen wo rum es geht jetzt soll es
der Bundesregierung also ganz schnell
gehen noch im April soll ein
Gesetzesentwurf vorgelegt werden und
noch in diesem Jahr soll Cannabis
legalisiert werden unter bestimmten
Voraussetzungen wir sprechen darüber mit
meiner Kollegin Nicole Dieckmann in
Berlin die ist uns noch zugeschaltet
Nicole es soll zwei Säulen geben lass
uns erstmal auf die erste blicken was
ist denn als nächster Schritt konkret
geplant
soll sogenannte Cannabis-Clubs geben mit
maximal 500 Mitgliedern diese Cannabis
Clubs sollen wenn ich das richtig
verstanden habe pro Mitglied fünf
Pflanzen anbauen dürfen und
pro Mitglied und unter 21 Jahren 30
Gramm maximal rausgeben dürfen pro Monat
an Cannabisprodukten wie Haschisch und
Marihuana und an über 21-Jährige maximal
50 g pro Monat das ist die eine Säule
ich glaube ich muss mal einmal die
Brille aufsetzen und sie ist richtig das
genau das ist so ähm zusammengefasst das
was die erste Säule ausmacht die
sogenannte schnelle Säule wie es eben
Bundesgesundheitsminister Karl
Lauterbach formuliert hat genau und dann
soll es ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher ob
es 21 oder 25 sind ich habe mir 25 Jahre
aufgeschrieben das wo die Altersgrenze
genau liegt das können wir aber noch mal
nachlesen und nach äh liefern das ist
also das erste hast du zusammengefasst
und das geht ja dann jetzt tatsächlich
auch sehr schnell und das zweite ist
dann dass es Modellregionen geben soll
aus denen am Ende auch Geschäfte
entstehen können wo man dann kommerziell
auch Cannabis kaufen und verkaufen kann
genau das ist jetzt der Kompromiss da
hat man sich also den Bedenken und den
möglichen Verstößen gegen EU-Recht
gebeugt ursprünglich war mal vorgesehen
dass zum Beispiel Apotheken oder auch
extra dafür noch einzurichtende
Geschäfte die Erlaubnis bekommen sollen
Cannabis zu verkaufen das hat man jetzt
kassiert und dafür eben die zweite Säule
die sogenannten regionalen Lieferketten
sich ausgedacht das sind regionale
Modellversuche die auf 5 Jahre erstmal
befristet sind und
währenddessen soll es ein sogenanntes
Monitoring geben also es soll immer
wieder
Zwischenfazit sollen immer wieder
zwischen Fazit gezogen werden wie
funktioniert das eigentlich welche
Auswirkungen hat das auf den regionalen
Schwarzmarkt also
ganz platt ausgedrückt was bedeutet das
eigentlich für die Dealer die man ja
bekämpfen will mit diesen heute
vorgestellten Eckpunkten und das weiß
ganz interessant zu hören die
EU-Kommission hatte ja bedenken hatte
massive Einwände gegen die
ursprünglichen Ideen der Bundesregierung
und nun erhofft man sich wenn man dieses
Modellprojekt fünf Jahre laufen lässt in
fünf Jahren ist diese Regierung übrigens
so wahrscheinlich nicht mehr im Amt
zwischendurch wird noch mal gewählt das
ist deswegen auch von der Zeitspanne her
ganz interessant sollte sich dieses
Modellprojekt
bewähren das ist die Hoffnung zumindest
von Karl Lauterbach so hat er es eben
formuliert dann könnte das eine
Strahlkraft haben so sagte es auch der
MS der mir der ja neben ihm saß auf den
Rest der EU man erhofft sich also
Mitstreiter zu finden die dann das
deutsche Modell dass die beiden eben
hier vorgestellt haben die das mittragen
Nicole ich krieg hier gerade aus dem
Team die Meldung du hattest recht es
sind unter 21-Jährige die die 30 Gramm
kennen sollen die Grenze ist 21 nicht 25
also da hattest du recht zwei politische
Fragen möchte ich gerne noch bei dir
unterbringen die eine kommt von Himbeer
Toni der fragt kommt das mit
Regierungsmehrheit durch wie sieht es
mit dem Bundesrat aus also was kann da
jetzt noch passieren bei dem bei der
Realisierung dieses Gesetzes vor das ist
eine gute Frage aber wir haben ja eben
schon einmal durch dekliniert
Bundesregierung ist dafür die linke ist
dafür das könnte also durch den
Bundesrat gehen
wenn ich die Mehrheiten richtig im Kopf
habe dann noch eine Frage was er
auffällt ist wir haben einen äh eine
Dreierkonstellation und der Regierung
wir sahen aber nur zwei Minister von der
SPD und von den Grünen und der FDP
Kollege der war nicht dabei weil er im
Urlaub ist
interpretiere ich da jetzt zu viel rein
oder tritt man dem Kollegen da so ein
bisschen vors Knie indem man in die
möglichkeit gibt mit einem politischen
Thema mit dem man gerade in der
jungwählergruppe sehr gut punkten kann
auch vor die Öffentlichkeit zu treten
oder ist das Zufall ich nehme an du
sprichst jetzt von Marco buschnann dem
Bundesjustizminister also dazu muss man
zwei Dinge sagen Buschmann hat gestern
ihre wem ihre Gebühr die Kollegen von
der ARD hatten das Vorlegen gestern
exklusiv ein Papier vorgelegt in dem es
um den Kampf gegen Hass im Netz geht das
ist ein Vorstoß aus der Ampel der hat
also gestern schon einige Punkte gemacht
man darf sich nichts vormachen auch wenn
es eine Koalition ist natürlich geht es
immer auch um das Prestige in der
eigenen Partei bzw der eigenen Partei
beim Wähler und bei der Wählerin dass
das eine das zweite ist ich habe das
eben schon mal angedeutet bevor sich aus
dem mir und Lauterbach in die
Bundespressekonferenz gesetzt haben
es ist sehr ungewöhnlich ein Eckpunkte
Papier zu präsentieren das ist das eine
das hat jetzt an Ungewöhnlichkeit
noch mal hinzugewonnen als Cem Özdemir
eben verkündete dass man noch in diesem
Monat einen Gesetzentwurf vorlegen wolle
das ist eigentlich der Zeitpunkt mit dem
an dem man an die Öffentlichkeit tritt
das verstärkt den Eindruck dass
Lauterbach und Özdemir die Osterwoche
die nach Osterwoche in der wir ja noch
stecken nutzen um PR zu machen denn das
ist innenpolitisch keiner allzu
Nachrichten starke Zeit du hast es eben
schon gesagt die einen oder anderen
Minister sind gerade im Urlaub sind gar
nicht hier und das zahlt zum einen aufs
eigene Konto ein zum anderen aber auch
aufs Konto der Ampel der derzeit nicht
gerade einig und wahnsinnig
handlungsfähig im Moment ein gewirkt hat
vor allem in den letzten Wochen als es
z.B um den heizungsstreit ging also ähm
ich glaube man nimmt das in Kauf das
muss man heute nicht dabei sein kann
dass die FDP da heute nicht mit am Tisch
saß weil man sich profilieren möchte
auch nicht zu vergessen Karl Lauterbachs
Image hat in den letzten Monaten doch
hin und wieder einige Kratzer abgekommen
z.B in der Corona Diskussion
sagt unsere Hauptstadt Korrespondentin
Nicole Dieckmann Dankeschön dass du auch
heute wieder bei uns im Stream warst
heute zu diesem Thema Dankeschön für die
Einschätzungen nach Berlin immer gerne
und damit gehen wir jetzt ein bisschen
weg vom politischen und Meer zum
inhaltlichen medizinischen wie
gefährlich ist Kiffen wie groß ist die
Suchtgefahr wie groß ist die Gefahr für
Kinder und Jugendliche alle diese Fragen
könnt ihr gerne stellen wie immer in die
Chats und in die Kommentare oder per
Mail an die bekannte E-Mail-Adresse und
das alles geht an einen Experten der
sich damit sehr gut auskennt und jetzt
bei uns hier im Stream dabei ist er ist
der ärztliche Direktor der Klinik für
sucht Medizin und abhängiges Verhalten
in Stuttgart herzlich willkommen dr
Maurice cabanes
guten Tag unter cabanes diesen Namen
muss man erstmal wirken lassen in diesem
Zusammenhang sie heißen dr kabanes und
beschäftigen sich mit den Auswirkungen
von Cannabis wie schmerzfrei sind sie
bei sprachwitzen das müssen wir erstmal
klären sonst können sich hier alle nicht
mehr auf die Inhalte konzentrieren
das stimmt also ich bin da ganz
schmerzfrei im Gegenteil es ist immer
ein super eisbreaker wie man jetzt auch
sieht man kommt gut ins Gespräch am
Anfang und ich kann jeden verstehen der
erstmal stutzig wird bei dem Namen und
es gibt viele verschiedene
der Legalisierung also schon seit
Schulzeiten mich damit konfrontiert das
einzige was mich immer überrascht ist
dass manche Menschen noch davon
überzeugt sind sind sie dass sie dass
das erste mal zu mir sagen und ich das
noch nie gehört habe aber trotzdem finde
ich immer sehr sympathisch und gibt die
Möglichkeit direkt zu den Austausch zu
kommen wunderbar dann haben wir das
geklärt und dann gehen wir direkt in den
inhaltlichen Austausch sie haben die
Pressekonferenz verfolgt was halten sie
von den Vorschlägen von den Ideen von
den Eckpunkten die schon bald ein
Gesetzesentwurf werden sollen der
Bundesregierung
grundsätzlich ist es glaube ich klar
dass es viele wichtige Argumente für
eine Legalisierung gibt
und ehrlicherweise der eine Punkt der
immer überraschend war in der Diskussion
dass man eben sehr auf die
leergilisierung gesetzt hat wissen dass
es auch ein längerer Prozess ist um sich
auf diesen Weg zu machen die
verschiedenen politischen
Konstellationen
national und international sind ja schon
erwähnt worden dass man weiß man möchte
das ganze legalisieren man nimmt aber in
Kauf das über einen längeren Zeitraum
Menschen nach wie vor illegalisiert
werden bis dann die Legalisierung
stattfindet und das ist jetzt natürlich
eine Möglichkeit die gefunden wurde dass
man einen Übergang schafft und auch
schnell möglicherweise reagieren kann
jetzt muss man gucken ob die Taten
folgen
dass man eben die Menschen die
voraussichtlich in der Zukunft nicht
mehr strafrechtlich verfolgt werden
jetzt schon die Situation haben auch
wenn es noch keine lizenzierte Abgabe
oder keinen größeren legalen Verkauf
gibt trotzdem keine bis besitzen und
konsumieren dürfen ohne zu befürchten
ohne befürchten zu müssen dass sie dann
strafverfolgt werden
hier gibt es viele Kommentare manche
gehen auch in Richtung gegen
Legalisierung da sind viele Userinnen
und User eine Gefahr ein User namens
denn die Idee schreibt z.B über Youtube
Einstiegsdroge mehr ist es nicht was
sagen sie als Sucht Mediziner dazu
ja das ist eben eine Haltung die
gewissen Substanzen gegenüber bestehen
und wo auch in der Diskussion ja immer
wieder auf die Diskrepanz aufmerksam
gemacht wird wie unterschiedlich mit
Substanzen umgegangen wird man kann
sagen dass die wichtigsten Substanzen
die abhängig machen als Einstieg dienen
nach wie vor Zigaretten und Alkohol sind
das ist natürlich kein Argument dafür
dass man jetzt einfach sagt naja dann
müssen wir alle möglichen anderen Dinge
auch legalisieren gleichzeitig ist es
aber ein Argument
dass man doch bestimmte Substanzen
stigmatisiert und es sich lohnt darüber
nachzudenken ob vielleicht ein anderer
Umgang mit den Substanzen auch eine
andere Möglichkeit Menschen zu helfen
oder zu unterstützen die diese
Unterstützung für sich als richtig
erachten also das meine ähm
zusammenfassend das selbstverständlich
mit allen Substanzen die wir zu uns
nehmen Gefahren verbunden sind ein paar
Celsius hat das gesagt die Dosis macht
das Gift und jede Substanz hat gefahren
dass sie schädlich wirken können und
auch das Cannabis so offen muss man sein
hat gefahren dass sie schädlich wirken
können auch das hat die Gefahr dass man
in Abhängigkeit geraten kann aber das
muss nicht passieren und es ist eben
möglich einerseits in dem
gesellschaftlichen Kontext zu
konsumieren im Sinne von vielleicht
Genuss oder diese Substanz zu gebrauchen
und es gibt dann die Situation in die
Menschen geraten die es dann vielleicht
nutzen zum Beispiel um sich selbst zu
medizieren in bestimmten Bereichen weil
sie sonst kein anderes Angebot haben und
es gibt die Situation dass Menschen
aufgrund von bestimmten Konstellationen
Abhängigkeit geraten aber das ist eben
das was jetzt auch als Argument gebracht
wird dass man die Chance hat früher
Menschen zu erreichen die das
Konsumieren das Verbot verhindert nicht
dass Menschen konsumieren und das die
Legalisierung verändert auch nicht dass
Menschen konsumieren aber die
Möglichkeit das mit diesem Verbot
gewisses Stigmata und auch Befürchtungen
verbunden sind die können sich
reduzieren und so hat man vielleicht die
Möglichkeit Menschen früher zu erreichen
die Sorge hatten zum Beispiel dann auch
strafrechtliche Konsequenzen zu erwarten
oder andere Dinge erwarten und das gilt
es jetzt natürlich zu adressieren es
klang jetzt sehr gut der Jugendschutz
ist wichtig die vorbereitungs ist
wichtig aber das konkret zu machen und
tatsächlich auch zu sehen dass diese
Strukturen gut aufgebaut werden und
funktionierend aufgebaut werden das ist
eben die andere Seite und das wird jetzt
noch viel Arbeit brauchen um das möglich
zu machen
über den medizinischen Gebrauch da wird
auch hier viel gesprochen gibt es auch
viele Fragen zu dazu kommen wir gleich
ich möchte nur eine Frage noch zur Menge
auch stellen weil sie das gerade auch
angesprochen sie haben die Dosis
angesprochen aber hier gibt's noch eine
Frage zur Menge Fu fragt auch über
Youtube noch weniger bitte 30 Gramm ist
viel zu viel und führt wirklich zu
Problemen das spricht ja die 30 Gramm an
die für den Eigenbedarf erlaubt sein
sollen es sind ja auch wenn man
erwachsenes über 21 bis zu 50 Gramm pro
Monat erlaubt was sagen sie denn dazu
grundsätzlich ist es so dass es immer
schwierig ist Grenzen zu setzen
grundsätzlich die sind immer künstlich
weil man immer argumentieren kann naja
bei einem Alter was ist jetzt wenn ich
jetzt zwei Monate vor bin oder zwei
Monate nach bin an irgendeiner Stelle
muss das festgesetzt werden und
tatsächlich ist es auch bei den Dosis
Mengen dass man sich auseinandersetzen
muss wie viel ist jetzt eine Dosis die
einen in Gefahr bringen kann oder eben
nicht in Gefahr bringen kann und es ist
schwer festzulegen aus dem Alltag heraus
und dem Austausch mit Menschen die
Substanzen gebrauchen
scheint es erstmal eine angemessene
Menge zu sein das kann man auch ins
Ausland gucken auf wo höhere Mengen
vorhanden sind die möglich sind es ist
ja nicht so dass es Cannabis eben allein
an der Grammzahl die Gefahr sich äußert
sondern auch an den Bestandteilen die
das Cannabis enthält und da ist es sehr
unterschiedlich also ich kann zum
Beispiel wenn ich ein sehr hohen
cbd-anteil haben eine größere Menge auch
an Cannabis zu mir nehmen ohne in diese
vollgestörung oder gefahren zu haben
kommt immer darauf an Release konsumiere
natürlich wenn ich es rauche sind über
die üblichen Risiken die auch mit dem
Rauchen verbunden sind vorhanden aber
ich kann zum Beispiel auch
Zusammensetzung haben wo der THC Gehalt
extrem hochgezüchtet ist und dann sind
auch schon geringere Dosis Mengen oder
können gewisse geringe Dosis Mengen
gefährlicher sein das hängt aber auch
immer daran davon ab wie tolerant man
dem Gegenüber ist und wie man das
verträgt und jeder Mensch hat auch einen
unterschiedlichen Stoffwechsel so dass
man es wirklich schwer festlegen kann
was jetzt geeignet ist ich würde es eher
auf eine individuellen Ebene sehen und
da ist meine große Bedingung auch dass
man die Menschen gut aufklärt so dass
sie auch ihre Risiken besser einschätzen
können dass man selber feststellt welche
Mengen vertrage ich welche Mengen
vertrage ich nicht wo ab welchen Dosis
Mengen sind gewisse Risiken größer oder
geringer und dann selbst wie viel
Entscheidung für sich treffen können ob
man eben bereit ist dieses Risiko mit
einzugehen oder nicht
das heißt damit wäre auch quasi eine
Frage einer Userin namens Marion
mitbeantwortet die hat gefragt wie viel
Wirkstoff ist okay das ist also offenbar
eine sehr individuelle Antwort die man
dann darauf finden muss dann kommen wir
zu den medizinischen Aspekt da gibt es
verschiedene
Themen die das berührt Andrea Reinhard
fragt wie wirkt sich Cannabis auf
psychisch Kranke aus Diana Kubik fragt
über Facebook inwieweit hilft es
Menschen die mit Demenz Leben da haben
Sie sicherlich sehr viele therapiefelder
wo sie das Einsetzen die darüber
stehende Frage noch mal das was heute
entschieden wurde hat mit der
medizinischen Behandlung mit Cannabis
eigentlich nichts zu tun oder
erstmal nicht genau vollkommen richtig
andererseits wenn Sie das Thema schon
ansprechen und vielen Dank auch an die
User dass sie das Thema ansprechen ist
das eine zweite spannende Frage denn die
Verschreibung von Cannabis und die
Wirksamkeit von Cannabis ist bei manchen
Erkrankungen besser bei manchen weniger
gut nachgewiesen da gilt es noch Studien
zu machen und die Wirksamkeit zu
überprüfen aber nach wie vor besteht
eine große Problematik auch für Menschen
die das aus medizinischen Gründen
benötigen das auch verschrieben zu
bekommen und auch da würde ich an die
Politik appellieren sich noch mal
stärker auch dafür einzusetzen dass die
verschreibungsmöglichkeiten größer
werden denn je nachdem ob ich eine
bestimmte Erkrankung habe habe ich es
deutlich schwieriger auch das Cannabis
verschrieben zu bekommen und das führt
zu sozialen Ungerechtigkeiten das führt
aber auch dazu dass
medizinische Behandlung die notwendig
sind dann eben für die Betroffenen sehr
kostenintensiv sein können und das ist
natürlich ein großes Problem das war
nicht das Thema heute ich würde das
Thema aber gerne trotzdem in Diskurs
belassen und darauf aufmerksam machen
das ist gute Gründe gibt auch
medizinisch Cannabis medizinisch zu
verordnen und dass man auch an dieser
Situation daran bleibt zurzeit ist es so
dass ein Menschen eben die Medizin als
medizinischen Gründen Cannabis brauchen
und das nicht finanziert bekommen dann
eher sich das über den illegalen Markt
besorgten weil das deutlich billiger ist
als das kann halt ist was man in der
Apotheke bekommt wenn ich hier in die
Chats gucke dann sehe ich das eine Frage
inzwischen fast alle anderen überlagert
und zwar die Frage nach dem
Straßenverkehr und nach der Frage mit
dem Auto fahren und dem
Führerscheinentzug ich kann die gar
nicht alle Vorlesen weil es so viele
Fragen sind ich nehme mal eine raus von
Müsli der fragt über Youtube wie sieht
es denn nun mit den Regelungen im
Straßenverkehr aus also wie kann ich das
nachweisen wie wird das kontrolliert und
welche Grenzen sollte es da aus ihrer
Sicht geben
das ist tatsächlich eine ganz ganz große
Herausforderung und da habe ich jetzt
das Glück habe ich sowieso in vielerlei
Hinsicht sucht Mediziner zu sein und
nicht Verkehrsmediziner und auch nicht
Politiker und auch nicht Jurist zu sein
das ist natürlich eine sehr
herausfordernde Fragestellung die ich
mir gar nicht zutraue so einfach zu
beantworten
was klar ist dass man unter Cannabis
eine verzögerte Reaktionsfähigkeit hat
und je nachdem wie gewohnt dich die
Substanz bin und wie hoch die Substanz
dosiert ist ist diese Reaktionsfähigkeit
stärker oder weniger stark eingeschränkt
so dass es Gefahren im Straßenverkehr
bedeutet und eben auch ein schädlicher
Konsum im Straßenverkehr zu
entsprechenden Konsequenzen führen kann
und genauso wie der Alkohol
reglementiert ist im Straßenverkehr
sollte es ist auch beim Cannabis sein
diese Mengen festzulegen tatsächlich
muss ich gestehen das liegt nicht an mir
und es ist auch so dass ich mich dazu
wenig auskenne um dazu nachhaltig was
sagen zu können das müssen wirklich
Verkehrsmediziner prüfen die dazu auch
Versuchsreihen an und das muss die
Politik und Juristen müssen das
entscheiden um das wirklich auch
wasserdicht zu machen und auch eine gute
Handlungslinie vorzugeben zu können wir
haben mal ins Eckpunktepapier geguckt da
steht erstmal nur folgendes drin ich
lese auch gerade mal vor die Grenzwerte
im Straßen schiffs- und Luftverkehr den
dürfen wir natürlich auch nicht
vergessen werden unter Einbeziehung der
einschlägigen Fachgremien geprüft also
es wird das stattfinden was sie gerade
angesprochen haben mit entsprechenden
Experten Regelungen über die
Zulässigkeit von Fahrten unter Einfluss
von Cannabis orientieren sich dabei
ausschließlich an den Erfordernissen der
Verkehrssicherheit müsste das dann
weitergehen
kabanes wie kann man können Sie das
vielleicht noch sagen wie kann man das
denn nachweisen wir kennen das von
Alkoholkontrollen da muss man ins
Röhrchen pusten aber wie weiß man denn
Cannabiskonsum nach
ja das ist tatsächlich relativ also den
Nachweis ist nicht schwierig aber den
akuten Konsum nachzuweisen ist schwierig
also wenn ich beim Alkohol Puste und
eine Promillezahl habe dann weiß ich
dass der Konsum nicht so weit zurücklegt
dann kann er bis es erstmal so dass die
regulären Testmöglichkeiten die man hat
zwar Nachweis dass ich Cannabis
konsumiert habe aber in welchem Zeitraum
das gewesen ist
kann man noch nicht ganz spezifisch
sagen oder zu welchem Punkt das erfolgt
ist so das ist auch sein kann dass ich
noch
Abbauprodukte vom Katern bis ausscheide
z.B im Urin obwohl ich selbst nicht mehr
unter der Einwirkung oder dem Einfluss
der Substanz stehe und das macht eben
sehr herausfordernd und auch da gilt es
dann eben Testmöglichkeiten zu
entwickeln es gibt da schon ähm auch
funktionierende Ansätze das zu
ermöglichen um die Beeinträchtigung
besser beurteilen zu können und eben
auch um den Konsum akuter nachweisen zu
können
dann lassen Sie uns noch darauf schauen
ähm wie man das in Zukunft auch mit dem
Blick auf andere Länder machen kann da
möchten wir gerne gleich noch einen
kleinen exkursunternehmen wir haben
Holland vorhin in der Pressekonferenz
angesprochen gehört wir haben auch
gesehen dass es in Portugal zum Beispiel
und in Kanada Legalisierung Projekte
gibt und gemeinsam schauen wir darauf
wenn Ricken fast das zusammen
zum Klischee der Niederlande gehören
diese Bilder wie der Käse mal eben einen
Joint kaufen im Coffeeshop seit 1976
dulden die niederländischen Behörden den
Verkauf für den Eigenbedarf allerdings
ist der Großhandel weiterhin verboten
auch die Coffeeshops müssen sich also
auf dem Schwarzmarkt eindecken
Schwörer macht man kann Cannabis kaufen
und verkaufen aber man darf es nicht
produzieren das hatte zur Folge dass für
die Produktion ein illegaler krimineller
Markt entstanden ist
die Folge die Niederlande sind zum
Umschlagplatz für Drogen auch harte
geworden und das Land ist fest im Griff
der Mafia ein Test in zehn Städten soll
das nun ändern dort soll das Cannabis
aus staatlich kontrollierter Zucht
kommen vier Jahre soll das dauern
portugal hat im Jahr 2000 den
Eigenkonsum aller Drogen
entkriminalisiert dort spricht man nicht
mehr von
illegalem Handel sondern von der
Versorgung kranker Menschen
wir versuchen eine gute Beziehung zu
Drogenabhängigen aufzubauen so dass sie
uns auch sagen wie sie ihn wirklich geht
seit 2001 ist die Zahl der Drogentoten
im Land um 75% gesunken die USA sind ein
Cannabis Flickenteppich in 18 Staaten
ist der Konsum legal doch längst nicht
überall darf es verkauft werden in
Washington DC führt das dazu das Händler
Mark sein Cannabis verschenkt
wenn ihr bei mir etwas kauft gebe ich
das Cannabis gratis dazu wenn du eine
Mütze ein Hemd oder auch einfach nur ein
Sportbeutel kaufst dann hast du Anspruch
auf Cannabis in der Rohstoff kommt unter
anderem aus Kalifornien hier ist auch
der Anbau von Cannabis legal es gibt
sogar pflanzkurse der den absolviert
darf sich dann offiziell Cannabis
Sommelier nennen
Cannabis Sommelier ähm Herr Dr kaban ist
wenn sie sich die Beispiele aus dem
Ausland anschauen und das was jetzt in
Deutschland geplant ist hat man da von
den guten Seiten gelernt setzt man da
das Gute um oder wiederholt man da
Fehler die woanders auch schon gemacht
wurden
also zumindest könnte man jetzt
argumentieren dass der Schritt diese
Modellprojekte einzuführen dazu dient
eben zu überprüfen wo mögliche Gefahren
bestehen und diese hoffentlich dass wir
wichtig dass man das dann aus den
Modellprojekten ableitet wenn man die
schon macht dann eben verbessert und
noch mal angeht es ist sicher so dass
bei diesem Beispiel sehr gut sichtbar
wird und das ist auch die Problematik
die wir haben das ist eben meistens
keine Entscheidung aus der
versorgungsperspektive allein ist
sondern dass es eben auch eine
politische Entscheidung ist die eben
häufig darauf basiert das Kompromisse
notwendig sind um eben Mehrheiten zu
erreichen und die darauf basieren dass
man eben bestimmten Regularien und
bürokratischen Anteilen gerecht werden
muss was dann zu solchen absurden Dingen
auch führt wie was in den Bericht gesagt
haben und gleichzeitig wird eben sehr
schnell sehr schön deutlich wie wichtig
ist ist darüber auch noch mal zu
sprechen und auch zu zeigen welche
absolidität vielleicht mit manchen
Dingen verbunden ist die im Rahmen
dieser Verbotspolitik
auftauchen und gleichzeitig die im
Grunde gar nicht so eine große
Verbesserung im Rahmen der Legalisierung
erzeugen weil es dann sehr kompliziert
wird sehr unübersichtlich wird Komplex
wird oder eben dazu führt dass man eben
versuchen muss irgendwelche
alternativwege zu finden wichtig ist
glaube ich der Aspekt der im Beitrag
auch ankam das ist eben eine Reihe von
Menschen gibt die den Substanz nicht nur
aus hedonistischen Gründen also um den
Genuss oder um gewissen Lifestyle zu
leben konsumieren das ist sondern dass
es eben auch eine Gruppe von Menschen
gibt die damit verbunden eine Erkrankung
entwickeln und eine Abhängigkeit
entwickeln oder zumindest einen Konsum
entwickeln den sie selbst als
problematisch empfinden und davon nicht
so einfach wegkommen und das hatte ich
ja schon versucht anzudeuten dass wir
eben die Chance die damit verbunden ist
dass man Strukturen aufbaut Menschen
früher zu erreichen und deswegen eben
auch die Frage mit dem mit der
Lizenzierung das damit vielleicht eine
Möglichkeit auch verbunden ist Menschen
im Rahmen dieser Verkaufstellen so zu
auszubilden
dass sie auch über die Risiken nicht nur
gut aufklären können sondern auch
aufklären können welche unterstützungs-
und Hilfemöglichkeiten gibt es wenn man
bemerkt dass es Probleme damit gibt
gleichzeitig diese Versorgungswege des
die Problematik des niederländischen
Modells das ist ja auch gut das ist
jetzt durch die Debatte mal klar
geworden ist dass es in Niederlanden
nicht einfach nur cool ist das ist
entkriminalisiert ist sondern das ist
auch mit vielen Problemen verbunden ist
und das wäre natürlich ein
entscheidender Weg des auch in
Deutschland
zu ermöglichen diesen Fehler eben nicht
zu machen und die Produktionswege und
Versorgungswege sicherer zu machen das
einzige das ist mir auch bei der
Pressekonferenz aufgefallen den
Irrglauben muss man nicht aufsetzen dass
man schafft dadurch den illegalen Markt
maßgeblich einzudämmen oder verschwinden
zu lassen es gibt viele Situationen wo
Menschen dann trotzdem auf diesen Markt
zurückgreifen das sind Kosten wenn das
Produkt eben günstiger auf dem illegalen
Markt zu erwerben ist das ist die
Altersgrenze muss man auch sagen dass
natürlich jüngere Menschen dann nach wie
vor nicht die Substanz wenn konsumieren
möchten dann illegal besorgen werden und
das dann eher auch da der Markt etwas
größer sogar dafür ist und deshalb der
der entscheidende Weg glaube ich ist und
da kann man sich von Portugal Portugal
auch wenn dies nur in kriminalisiert
haben viel abgucken dass die eben
ermöglichen wenn man mit den Substanzen
auffällig wird eben auch zügig zu
adäquaten Beratungs- und
Behandlungsangeboten zu kommen und es
ist das entscheidende dabei es hilft
nicht wenn ich jemanden eine Auflage
mache für eine Beratung oder Behandlung
und die Beratung und Behandlung ist dann
gar nicht attraktiv für diesen Menschen
oder die Person sondern es ist ganz
entscheidend dass ich dann auch in einem
Kontext komme wo ich sage ach ja ein
Glück dass mich jemand darauf aufmerksam
gemacht hat das empfinde ich jetzt auch
als hilfreich oder unterstützend also
das wäre für mich ein wesentlicher Teil
die man eben aus anderen Ländern anderen
Regionen lernen kann und eben wo man
entweder Fehler nicht machen muss oder
Sachen übernehmen kann die funktionieren
können
das findet auch eine Userin namens
Marion die schreibt ich finde es sollte
mehr Aufklärung geben und dann lassen
Sie uns abschließend noch mal über die
Aufklärung hinausgehen zu einem Schritt
davor nämlich zur Prävention wenn wir
uns anschauen dass der Genuss von
Cannabis vor allem für Kinder und
Jugendliche gefährlich sein kann wenn
das Hirn noch nicht voll entwickelt ist
die Möglichkeit Psychosen auszubilden
die gibt es offenbar gerade in diesen
jüngeren Gruppen wie wichtig ist dann
das Stichwort Prävention
ja vielen Dank für die Frage das ist ein
ganz wichtige Frage und da kommt genau
das Thema vielen Dank auch für den
Begriff der Aufklärung mit ins Spiel das
große Problem das ist nicht nur in
Deutschland das Problem das ist
international das Problem dass es wenig
Angebote wenig Leitlinien und auch wenig
Ideen dazu gibt wie man Prävention gut
aufstellen kann und auch damit verbunden
nicht nur die Prävention sondern auch
die Frühintervention also dass man so
früh wie möglich Menschen erreicht bevor
so eine Abhängigkeitserkrankung eben
chronisch wird und dann auch schwer zu
behandeln ist und bei der Aufklärung
gibt es verschiedene Teile wichtig ist
dass man über Risiken aufklärt das ist
der Begriff und aufzeigt wie gut es auch
ist auf Substanzen zu verzichten auf der
einen Seite auf der anderen Seite aber
zu wissen wenn man sich um Prävention
kümmert dass das eben nicht die
Leitlinie ist für viele junge Menschen
die eben sich erproben die in der Phase
sind wo sie neugierig sind wo sie auch
bereit sind eben gewisse Risiken
einzugehen und auch in der Gemeinschaft
vielleicht aus auch aus Spaß Gründen
gemeinsam einen Versuch machen zu
konsumieren und das auch als Spaß sich
erleben und das kann dann eben in
einzelnen Fällen auch zum
problematischen Konsum übergehen deshalb
ist es so wichtig auch die Menschen
darüber aufzuklären worauf muss ich
achten wenn ich konsumiere was ist
wichtig
zu beachten wenn ich bestimmte Symptome
feststelle wo kann ich hingehen wo kann
ich Unterstützung erfahren was sind
Sachen auf die ich besonders Acht geben
muss oder Fragen die Stellen sollte wenn
mir bestimmte Substanzen angeboten
werden und da gibt es zumindest am
Klinikum Stuttgart jetzt die gute
Möglichkeit dass wir mit der Universität
in Sydney zusammenarbeiten die
mitgliederinstitute es ist ein Institut
dass die gesamte Prävention für
Australien reguliert und die einen
Präventionsprogramm entwickelt haben das
nennt sich kleines schools dass darauf
setzt eben diese Aufklärung zu betreiben
also das heißt sie haben die haben
zusammengearbeitet mit Disney und so
kritisch man vielleicht auch Disney
manchen Punkten sehen kann ist es so
dass sie schaffen ähm Figuren
zu erzeugen mit denen sich Kinder
Jugendliche gut identifizieren können
und in dem Rahmen begleitet man dann in
einem Comic junge Menschen die eben
Substanzen ausprobieren oder darauf
verzichten und wird dann um die
einzelnen Substanzen mit deren Folgen
konfrontiert eben auch unter anderem mit
dem Cannabis und das was man
festgestellt hat in Australien ist dass
die Schüler Schülerinnen das sehr sehr
gut annehmen dass die das ist gelingt
eben einerseits im Selbststudium sich
mit den Comics auseinanderzusetzen und
dann eben vor Ort über diese Dinge zu
sprechen und gleichzeitig Anlaufstellen
zu haben und das haben die Kollegen
schon seit zehn Jahren dort und Kollegen
seit zehn Jahren in Australien in der
Anwendung und konnten sehr gut zeigen
dass nicht nur der Konsum an sich
runtergeht sondern dass die Menschen die
konsumieren auch deutlich weniger
konsumieren also weniger Konsum Tage
haben und dass wir jetzt hier in
Stuttgart noch machen und da kommen wir
genau an diesen Übergang zur
Frühintervention dass wir dieses
Programm anbieten wir haben das ins
Deutsche übersetzt adaptiert und
erforschen das gerade an Schulen wie das
wird was Schüler brauchen und können
dann so das Programm auch an aufpassen
und was wir dazu gefügt haben ist dass
man im anonymes chatmöglichkeit hat über
dieses
Online-Angebot und erstmal Fragen
stellen kann ohne gleich zu einer
Suchtberatungsstelle zu müssen ohne
gleich zum
zu den Eltern gehen zu müssen oder
ähnliches sondern erstmal eine kurze
Beratung zu erhalten und was sie zeigt
ist das über diese Möglichkeit erstmal
anonym einzusteigen ganz häufig dann die
Chance besteht dass man dann auch
überführt und dann Unterstützung nicht
mehr anonym sondern direkt geben kann
und das Besprechen kann und dann eben
Menschen die in Sorge sind junge
Menschen die in Sorge sind sehr sehr
früh helfen kann und das denke ich ist
ein ganz entscheidende Sache das muss
nicht dieses Projekt sein sondern
entscheidend ist dass man sich Gedanken
darüber macht was ist in der Presse
Prävention wichtig wie sollte die
aufgestellt sein und die auch dann
flächendeckend und gut strukturiert
anzubieten und auch nicht abhängig davon
zu machen das ist schon das nächste
Problem wie die Besetzung an Schulen ist
und wie die Voraussetzungen die
technischen Voraussetzungen an Schulen
sind oder ähnlichem sondern das ist ganz
wichtig dass man
die den Drive der jetzt da ist nutzt
sich differenziert mit
Präventionsprogramm auseinanderzusetzen
und die auch weitläufig einzubieten und
dann reden wir sicherlich auch nicht nur
übers kiffen sondern auch über die
Gefahren von Nikotin und Alkohol aber
das ist ein weites Feld man muss es
zusammendenken vielen Dank dass Sie mit
uns einen Anfang gemacht haben sagt Dr
Maurice kabanes vom Klinikum Stuttgart
zur geplanten Legalisierung von Cannabis
danke schön dass Sie bei uns im Stream
waren danke schön nach Stuttgart
und wenn ich hier abschließend auch an
die User und Userin Entschuldigung
vielen Dank
jetzt erwischt mich der Heuschnupfen
noch vor der Verabschiedung 30 Sekunden
hätte man es jetzt noch schaffen können
aber ich verschaffe es noch
zusammenzufassen was ich hier in den
Chats sehe ich habe sehr viele Fragen
zum Thema Führerschein gesehen ich habe
sehr viel Positives gelesen über die
geplante Legalisierung viele kritische
Kommentare gab es natürlich auch wir
hoffen dass wir die Argumente der Gegner
auch hier gut abgebildet haben und zu
Wort kommen lassen haben und ich möchte
gerne schließen mit einem Kommentar von
einem User namens Benji the best der
oder sie schreibt ich bin ja generell
gegen Drogen auch gegen Alkohol und
Zigaretten etc ich finde wenn man das
erlauben kann dann kann man Cannabis
auch erlauben die Idee ist reguliert zu
legalisieren finde ich sinnvoll
damit sagen wir hier vielen Dank fürs
mit diskutieren und fürs mit Fragen und
fürs dabei sein bis zum nächsten Mal
tschüss